A little bit DMX. Um, dude, I, uh,
I don't really know where to start this podcast, to be honest it's uh,
cause yesterday was the day that, um,
I don't want to start with on too much of a down downer, but like,
I found out, you know,
Kobe Bryant died like at noon yesterday when I was waking up bright and
early at noon. And, um, I just couldn't believe it, man.
Um, I couldn't, I couldn't believe it.
It's so weird that he died and the way he did,
I got to say, first of all, I cried like all day,
which I'm not trying to make it about me,
but it's so weird that I cried all day because I, I didn't really,
I don't care about basketball. I don't, uh,
I don't know much about Coby except for, you know, he, um,
you know, he played basketball. He's one of the greatest of all time. And, uh,
and I just don't, I don't know if I, uh, I didn't know, I cared that much.
And then when I found that out about how he's 41 and a helicopter crash,
I don't, I also, like, I'd never witnessed somebody,
uh, a turn, the air off it's bugging me. I never noticed about, um,
I never noticed how much, like there were,
so in my life, somebody dying like prematurely,
or like even the Robin Williams thing or the, uh,
Michael Jackson, I was 29 when Michael Jackson died. And Robin Williams,
when he died, it was like six years ago.
And Robin Williams was in like in my circle, in my life, like,
like we talked about him all the time, I'm a comedian, he was a comedian. Um,
I met Robin Williams once and talked with him for a little bit and just, um,
that was rough. But for some reason,
the Kobe Bryant thing really hit me hard. Like, I mean,
maybe it's because we're the same age,
maybe it's cause I'm going to be a dad or some.
And his daughter was in the helicopter and it just really.
And it me up the whole day.
And I had a show in Irvine and I wasn't sure if I was
going to be able to do it the way I do. I mean,
I knew I'd be able to go on stage and you know, I'm a professional,
I'll be able to get on stage and do the. But I wasn't sure if I was gonna,
you know, give,
be able to do it a hundred percent now, you know, I was able to,
I got on stage and it was all good. It was fine. Which I don't know.
Maybe I just like, was crying for I four or five times.
I just like people would send me videos of what, of him.
And then an hour before Showtime, I was like, all right, you guys,
you gotta stop, man. I can't, I'm going to be like upset on stage.
I just didn't know.
I'm surprised how big of a deal he was to the world.
Like there's nobody who didn't know who Colby Bryan was.
Everybody knows who Kobe Bryant is. You're seven years old.
You know who Kobe Bryant is. And he only retired like three years ago,
which I didn't even realize three, four years ago. It's still fun.
It kind of felt like he played basketball in a way.
And then the thing the other night,
like the 10 hours before LeBron passed him in scoring or whatever it was. And,
and then Colby was in the news the night before,
and then in the news for being celebrated and then in the news for being so such
in such a tragedy, it was just so awful, man. I just,
my heart goes out to his family and, and I mean, dude,
I was watching some of the clips, like people were just talking about how,
like he put LA, he made LA cool again. He made LA I, it just,
I don't realize like, you know,
I make fun of my opener a lot because he likes sports and he's 35. And like,
he doesn't, he's a comedian. I'm like, bro, just hang it up. You know,
like stop shooting a basketball at the YMCA. You're 35,
have a child. You know what I mean? Work on your jokes.
The guy is so competitive. It's like, he's like,
you don't think I could jump further than you I'm like, bro, I don't give a.
I'm 39. You know,
if you're not getting paid to do anything with a ball,
give it up when you're 24. But my,
my opener is just like, let's go, let's go. Let's play.
You don't think I could do it. And I'm like,
I don't not only do I not even think or not think I don't care,
but the point is, is basketball
when there's somebody like that, that transcends it. It's about an idea.
It's about, it's not even him, which is it is him because you know,
he's a real person. I don't want to take that away from him. You know, you, you,
you make these people out to be bigger than they really are. And,
and you think about how they don't have, you know, they're,
you don't think of them as like real people, but he was a very real person,
but like it becomes about, it becomes an idea. You know,
like Kobe Bryant was an idea and he was helping women's basketball. He,
you know, the way he was with his daughter and she wanted to be in the w NBA.
And that's just beautiful. I mean, there's this clip on,
I think it's Jimmy Kimmel talking about how, um, uh,
Kobe was just like, you know,
he was talking about his daughter and they were saying about how like, Oh yeah,
don't you feel bad that you don't have any sons, you know,
you need someone to carry on your legacy and his daughter would cut them off and
be like, Whoa, that's me. I'm the legacy. And then how he was like, yeah,
you're right. You are the legacy.
And that's just so awesome that he had his daughter's back like
that. You know? I mean, look,
it's hard enough for women in, in certain ways.
And just the fact that he was like an out an ally for his daughters and like,
it was just so awesome. And it's, it's,
it's like people need that.
And now that he died in such a weird way,
it's about the idea. It's about the idea that died too. And, but, but,
but here's the thing that I did didn't die because you still have that idea,
you know, it's, it's, it's still lives on he's bigger than the person he was,
which is man. I mean, you know,
it's more than 99.9% of people can say,
and that's a beautiful thing. And it's so tragic the way he died.
And it's so tragic the way his, you know, H how it, how it happened,
but I mean, no blood it's tragic. However,
there is also the idea that lives on and that
is just, it's so special,
man. You know,
I don't get too serious on this podcast too much because we'd like to have a
silly goose time and, you know,
that's my idea that I want to get out there. Uh, but when there's a, you know,
and that's, but there's a real idea behind Kobe, Kobe Bryant. And,
and it's just, you know, it's really touching man, a guy like me for a guy,
like for a guy like me, who doesn't even watch basketball. You know,
there were kids out, there was nine year olds out there that were,
that were like mourning the loss of Kobe Bryant and 50 year olds out there that
were at the staple center that were like, you know, and, and,
and, you know, it's,
it's always a shame when somebody like that dies because they're not able to
witness the love for them. And, and the, and the togetherness that it,
it, it, it, you know, it brings us all together afterwards,
and they're not able to see it. Like even my buddy Brody Stevens, who,
who was a victim of suicide, like he, who, you know,
he killed himself and like to see that guy was always insecure about people
liking him. He thought, well, didn't like him. He thought, you know,
and he was one of the funniest guys I've ever met in my life.
And I would see him all the time at the comedy, sorry.
And he was a friend of mine and he killed herself. And, and,
and just the rallying that the, the people,
the community that the comedians, and then the people outside of,
of people who are comedians,
just fans that just got behind the idea of Brody Stevens.
It's, it's a beautiful thing, the sad but beautiful thing.
And it's also a shame that that person can never see it
because he would have loved to see in it. And, you know, I don't know.
It just may make, makes me think, you know, people say like,
grab your loved ones and let them know you love them. And,
and I suppose that's very important. Uh,
but my heart goes out, man, and that's sucks. And it's just a tragedy.
And hopefully in a few weeks or months, or however, a year, however long,
it takes you to grieve.
Like you can just start celebrating the idea that Kobe Bryant
was. And, um, and that's that, you know, I mean,
I think about Tupac all the time. I know I make jokes about how, you know,
I got, I got this, huh. On a loop here, you know,
and that's not really the idea that Tupac was behind someone's, but.
It was the, you know, to.
Me, Tupac, it, transcend hip hop, it transcended, uh,
his rap music. Like I.
He got me through certain times in.
You know, as silly as it is a suburban white kid,
but like high school and college and like that.
Now, whenever some goes down in the back of my head a little bit.
And it helps, but, uh, you know,
love or whatever, out there to all the,
all the people that are affected by this, God,
I can't believe how many people I've never witnessed something.
Even the Michael Jackson thing. I know it was,
I know Michael Jackson was probably bigger than Kobe,
but I've never seen something like, like this for, for,
for a celebrity that died. Uh, anyway, that's, uh, that's the,
uh, the, the real. And now we'll probably have a syllabus time. I mean,
I'm not, I don't ever promise you anything. It is what it is.
And we fly by the seat of our pants and my babies, and it's all good, but.
Uh, it's cool. It's also cool to me that someone can like, like,
LeBron's like this,
like that someone can be so easy.
In the spotlight. I mean, [inaudible].
And under a microscope and just, I mean, LeBron
just take LeBron, like, dude, where's his scandal.
How is LeBron? Just basically,
you know, Jesus.
Like, I don't want to get the Catholics mad even though who cares.
But like, even though who cares, right. Because it doesn't matter. Right.
I don't want to off the Catholics, but on one hand,
I don't want to off the Catholics. But on the other hand, who cares, right?
Couldn't care. A rat task in I'm talking about,
so why is LeBron so perfect?
How come nobody's like.
Yeah, LeBron got mad and choked.
Me like bro, who's that one? Chris Weber was that the guy,
who's the guy that choked the dude, that guy wasn't even LeBron.
And he was like, I'm going to choke someone. How the do you get everything?
LeBron, the guy has got the greatest family. Great.
You know, he's got planes and houses.
He listens to music on Instagram and makes this face.
That's his scandal. That's it, him turning it up on Instagram.
That guy is there a DM out there that can expose him? You know,
the guy's unreal. And just,
but my point is, how does he, like, if someone with him.
Ron, I feel like LeBron will be like, nah, that's not worth my time.
I'm bigger than that. I want to be the bigger person, bro.
How do you have everything? And also be the bigger person.
If I had everything, I'm going to be a small person.
If I had more than two pools, getting smaller,
dude, I swear to God. If I get a, like,
if I, if you ever see me, if I ever get a plane, if I ever get a plane,
I G for real, someone's going to have to throw me in because
I swear to God, ladder. They'll be like, Oh, look at that. Or that ladder down,
dude, are you kidding me? Pilot hit me up. Just chucked me in there.
Small person. Now, anytime some goes down. I'm petty.
Anytime some goes down. Somebody could be like, you know,
dude, I'm petty now, bro.
I have to force myself to not clap back or these trolls in Twitter, dude.
I have to force myself not to it. When someone talks to me on Twitter,
I have to force myself to turn this down. That pops in my head
when somebody is in my Twitter,
I swear to God. If I get a plane, I'm just
straight up. I'm going to be so small. People are going to be like, where is he?
And I'm going to be in the room.
Swear to God. I'll be in a cupboard somewhere. Just like laundering hard.
I'm Chucky. Swear to God. When I get a plane, I'm Chucky.
I'm getting overalls and a striped shirt and just stabbing that talk to me on
Twitter. Like how, how,
how does it happen? Look at these that lose their minds.
Look at Jared Leto. Hey Jared Leto. We get it.
You have 19 abs uh,
dude, you got abs touching your. We get it. They go all the way down.
We get it. Jared Leto.
You got abs that go from your Adam's Apple all the way down to the base of your
tank.
Also a petty because you got a
plane. When you get a plane, how do you not lose your mind?
LeBron? He's like, nah, nah. It's all good.
I'm an idea. That's amazing, dude.
I swear to God.
I just don't understand how you can do that. I mean,
I know people that are coming up now that are in the head and they're not even
barely famous. They got tickets to sell.
They got tickets left to sell and they're like,
I was with a buddy and I'm not even going to name them because he's a buddy,
but he snapped at another at a fan dude. And I was like, Whoa, bro,
what about becoming an I day? Yeah,
you don't even have a yet.
And this guy's like some fan came up, Hey,
when are you going to be on Rogan again? And the guy goes, the guy says,
I don't know
what about LeBron, dude?
You.
Don't even have a pool that you don't share with someone.
You got a pool that you share with some families because in a
complex and it's fine, but don't snap.
What about being.
Ron?
I know some of these guys coming up, dude, and they're just petty dude.
And I, you know, I try to keep a check on that, man.
But like I'm not even talking about petty. I'm talking about like.
I know some comedians, man. And they're just jealous bro. And it's like,
why we're all in this together.
The second a person gets bigger. That's in standup.
The second they get bigger, it's better for me. Why don't you realize that
the more it's better for all of us, the more it's better for all of them.
Gosh.
If you go on a tour with somebody, you know, uh,
if I was going to go on a tour with Bobby Lee or whatever the and we were just
now, you know what?
I don't want to work with that guy because this happened in that habit,
Bobby he's like,
I don't want to work with that guy because his lips are always wet and he looks
like a bird. And I say to Bobby, I don't want to work with Bobby anymore.
Cause he's literally a cartoon. And he's 50, even though he's 12
and now we talk and then we don't go on tour together. Guess what?
We lose out on each other's fans and it's not as good for each
other. I mean, I got one buddy. That's just trying to, that.
Just thinks everyone's out to get him, dude.
I'm not going to tell you if he's an actor or a comedian,
but he thinks that everybody is out to get him dude.
And he's it up for himself. And I want to talk to the dude,
but he's so hard to talk to. And I know that if we talk to it,
if we talk to each other, he's going to get defensive
and he's it up for himself, dude. Cause he's about to have it all.
And I just want to be like, what about planes dude?
And quite frankly, that's the T
quite frankly, that's the T and I don't say that kind of.
Cause you pretty much have to be like either a woman or gay to say that's the T,
but I'll say it as a heterosexual male. That's the tea.
So I don't know. I don't know, man. It's just,
how are you not rooting for people? How are you not rooting for people?
How are you not out there rooting for people? How do you let this?
And I'm petty, but I'm petty to a point. If somebody talks, I talk. I told you
and I'm very in, but dude,
that's where it stops. How are you not rooting for people, man?
They're people that when they do well, if everyone's doing well,
everyone's doing well. How is that something so hard to understand.
Especially in the same business dude peeler. So jealous man. And you know,
I guess I get that way sometimes, but I try to think about it.
And I came from a good family. So like I had a leg up, you know,
my parents taught,
taught me well and not everybody has taught has had good parents and not
everybody has had a life of privilege. Okay.
But still dude, there's people out there that were straight up by their uncle,
that.
Businesses and our good ideas.
You know?
So at the end of the day, um,
a rising tide lifts all boats. And I don't know really what that means,
but one fire wrote it and it's true.
And I do know what it means. A rising tide lifts all boats. That's the truth,
a rising tide, one fire that's the one thing he typed on the thing today.
For some reason he thinks he's God Confucius and it's fine, dude,
but it's true. A rising tide lifts all boats, dude.
So get in the boat here it comes.
I'm just going to have temperature.